you gave Nicole the advice and I think
the Oscars to clap with her hands like
this she shaded me so hard she did that
became like such a meme everybody was
talking about it I wish that there was
more important things to be concerned
about other people were focused on more
important thing listen I thought it was
amazing I mean when it happened I was
like oh my god Nicole Kidman just I'm
asking her about her clapping and she
clapped back at me I was like oh my god
this is amazing I think she just shaded
me a little bit yeah she did listen it
was already so cold yeah that I was just
dying already know a little a little
piece of me died inside but then I also
know that it was funny
yeah and that it was great fodder and he
of course was Kathy Griffin's New Year's
Eve replacement on CNN after her Trump
head photo got her banned from the
broadcast the controversial artwork had
Cathy blacklisted from Hollywood and
even ended her friendships with both
Andy and Anderson months later Cathy
made some damning accusations about the
talk show folks I've actually done watch
what happens live with Andy Cohen twice
old times I did the show right before we
went live Andy Cohen privately asked me
if I wanted to do blow Andy has since
denied Cathy's claims
given that you guys did so well a New
Year's Eve together did you hear at all
from Kathy Griffin about how that went
down
I didn't she's not she hasn't been
texting me lately yeah she used to text
me about yeah yeah but not but currently
now now given that you have interviewed
so many people over the course of your
career we have I really do um probably
when Oprah was on that was that meant a
lot to me because I admire her so much
I'm gonna say I've seen 85% of every
episode of The Oprah Winfrey Show over
25 years legitimately no joke so for her
to wind up in my teeny little Clubhouse
on my show it meant to it was a very big
deal to me it was a very special moment
you
got the chairs there from yes we know
yes we have the Oprah chairs that we
bought online what is your opinion on
the idea of everyone saying Oprah 2020
do you think this is a legitimate thing
that could happen you know look Oprah is
a great business woman and she's a more
successful businesswoman than Trump ever
was a businessman she's never declared
bankruptcy right her record is
crystal-clear yeah but I mean I wonder
also if you know it should be someone
who's kind of a light blonde who's been
in there before
one of the best things that you do on
the show when the herd needs to do on on
watch what happens live is plead the
fifth
okay the time has come for you to plead
the fifth
so we're gonna play some plead the fifth
grade okay okay three questions I mean
you know yes three questions I can plead
the fifth only you recently asked Celine
Dion if she had any advice for Lady gaga
about her Vegas residency would you
rather see if the lien or Gaga perform
in Vegas but my only thing is I've never
seen Celine Dion in concert I might say
her because I've never seen her and I've
seen Lady Gaga but I mean I loved them
both you've interviewed some the biggest
names in Hollywood who was the biggest
diva behind the scenes and what did they
do that made them so difficult well
Mariah Carey but I love her for being a
diva she's everything you want her to be
yeah I switched seats for her she was
late she's drinking out of a big goblet
I mean people were coming in like you
know taming her down I mean yeah one of
your best friends is sex and co-star
Sarah Jessica Parker yep is it true she
was mad at Kim Cattrall for saying no to
the third film it's a new film um
I think from what I gather I think she
was disappointed that they couldn't get
the movie made yeah because they all
felt like it was a great scrub yeah
and that character Samantha was featured
so heavily and that it was a wonderful
story for her so I think they were just
disappointed that the movie didn't get
me how would you like to see
Samantha's story wrap up well I mean you
know if you can't get him to try anyway
what's Sharon's don't hey yeah that's
what I'm saying
there it is I'd like to see the movie
with Sharon Stone